hello everyone and welcome to another
tamil technique class at home i hope you
are all doing fine
in today's video we will take the hero
elements from the previous video
and we will put them all together in a
combination
in a long combination so it would be a
combination for a hero
with the steps of the leader okay
to make it easier we will break this
combination into parts
yeah and on the first segment of the
video
we will do just the first part just the
first few steps
will be very easy and then on each
subsequent
segment of the video we will keep adding
steps
yeah we will add more steps and have
more steps until at the end of the video
we have the whole combination
yeah so if you want to to see how
the combination looks like you can jump
to the end of the video now
and have a look and then come back and
we do it all together in sequence
now i know that for uh leaders can be
sometimes difficult to
dance a relatively long combination by
themselves
alone without a partner and at the same
time
keep track of the followers step yeah
it's it's
difficult to do but in my opinion it's a
very good exercise and
it's actually a necessary exercise
because
when you're dancing with your partner
for real you know
you practically don't have time to think
about
what steps is she doing and of course
you're gonna look at her legs to find
out if you don't know
um you could practice with a partner if
you have one now
and look at her steps to understand what
she's doing
in each moment but then
that's okay to do it but if you only do
that
your understanding and memory
of her steps will be just visual
but if you spend some time by yourself
alone doing the fear and figuring out
what the woman is doing what the
follower is doing at each moment
then your understanding of the steps of
the follower
is much deeper because you have figured
it out yourself
and then when you go dancing with your
partner for real
it will be just second nature for you to
know where she is
and what can you do if you're
improvising
yeah so this will be the class today we
will start with the warm-up
and then once we are ready to work we
will do each part of the combination
in turn and each part
we will do it first slowly yeah so you
can focus on the technique
on clean movements on understanding the
steps
and also understanding what the follower
is doing we will do it both sides yeah
to the right
and to the left slowly and then we will
do it again
but fast in half time which would be the
speed that you would normally use
if you were dancing for real okay
so that's it let's go for the warm-up
okay what not so
as always we start with our feet
together yeah
and we spend the first few seconds just
relaxing
breathing deeply finding our center
and basically feeling our weight the
weight of our body
heavy on the floor through our feet yeah
and we start with shoulder circles
every exercise of the warm up has a
function
that applies to the angle to your tongue
and the function of this one yeah is to
relax the shoulders obviously
so that later when you embrace your
partner you have a nice posture for the
embrace a nice position
for your shoulders your shoulders are
down and relaxed
yeah that's what this does so remember
make the circle big and don't
use the arrows because some people do
this
yeah they i think what happens is that
they want to make the circle
so big that they use the elbows to help
now the elbows don't help leave the
elbows alone
just do it only with the shoulders okay
only with the shoulders we do it extra
slowly today
so that you pay attention to the elbows
that are relaxed
okay so we do it eight times ah one
two three
four five
six seven
and eight yeah if you do it more times
you will feel the upper back
very relaxed then we do circles
with the arms yeah and the function of
this exercise is basically
to further relax the shoulders and to
open the chest
that's the main thing so that when you
dance with your partner
especially if you dance in close embrace
your contact
with your partner is good
it feels good it's flat it's open
it's honest yeah so that's what
this exercise helps for the
contact with your partner yeah okay
so we do it eight times yeah remember
we start down we go forward we go up and
when we open we pass the hands a bit
behind the back
so you make sure that your chest opens
really well okay
so we do it eight times one
two three
four five
six seven
and eight okay then
we stretch the side of our torso
like this and the function of this
exercise for tango
is to help you put your back
really straight yeah we are bending the
back
to both sides so this helps balance the
and it helps us find this verticality
okay
and also this stretch it feels very good
and also makes uh helps the torso to be
a bit taller okay so we lift the arm
like this make sure it's pointing
directly up yeah and then the elbow is
not bent
yeah make it straight and then we slide
with the hand down the leg after you can
touch your knee
at least and then we hold this stretch
and then you pull yourself up again and
then drop the arm and then we repeat
with the other side yeah we do it four
times to each side
so let's start one go down
hold it and
up one
down hold it
and up two
slide down touch the knee hold it
and up and two
slide down touch the knee at least
hold it and up three
arm up slide down holding
and up and
three go down hold it
and up and the last one this side four
slide down the leg hold it
and up and four
slide down hold it
and up okay good now
we open the legs we bend the knees
slightly and we make sure that the feet
are looking forward yeah not open like
this but
forward and bending the knees will help
block
the hip because what we have to do now
is a circle with the arms
and twist the torso like this and this
exercise
is fundamental for tango because it has
to do with dissociation
which we need for pivots for launches
for heroes for
everything where the hip is turning yeah
and this is the movement that we need
for that for dissociation now the
mistake that many people do here
is to move the arms without the torso to
move the arms along
and if you do this your torso is not
working
yeah because the torso has to work for
this exercise so the arms have to move
together with the torso
in one piece in one block yeah
actually in this exercise the arms are
not doing anything
the work is being done by this
yeah by these muscles so this is what
you have to do
yeah rotate the back above
the hip yeah and don't move the hip
because if you do this
you are not working dissociation
obviously and this can
if you do it a lot this can be bad for
your knees
yeah your knees are doing this and
that's bad
so bend the knees that helps to block
them
and let's do it 16 times uh
to each side okay let's go one
two and three
four five and
six and seven and
eight eight more one and
two and three and
four and five and
six and seven and
eight okay now we stretch the legs
and we will stretch now the lower part
of the back
and the back of the legs and this
stretch
of the back of our body is very good
to improve the quality of our steps yeah
step forward
step back because it relaxes the muscles
behind your
leg and it makes your step more elastic
yeah better better quality so you grab
your hips
and then slowly make sure that your
knees are straight
you bend your torso forward until your
back is parallel
with the floor yeah you can hold this
position
a little bit if you want or bounce here
a little bit just to start stretching
slowly and then there is to
continue going down yeah use the weight
of your head
to go down and then bounce three times
bounce
bounce bounce and then
raise again slowly okay
so let's look eight times together
one go down continue going down
bounce pass bounce and
up two
go down pass
and up four
six palms bounce
pass and up
seven bounce bounce
palms and up and
eight bounce bounce pass
and up okay and now we will relax
the hips yeah relax the hips this is
good for everything that our legs need
to do
the movement of our legs starts in the
hip
so if we relax the hips these muscles
here
then the move the legs will move uh
in a much more free way yeah so that is
to make circles with the hips we start
back and then we move the hip to the
side
and then we move the hip forward and
then we move it to the other side and
then back and we make a
whole circle as big as you can yeah now
the mistake that many people do here
is that they get confused and they move
the head
yeah they move the head for some reason
they think the hip is here no the hip is
here yeah
if you look the head is
mostly in the same place all the time
yeah it doesn't move much
it's the hip that is moving yeah so make
sure that
you don't get confused and you're moving
the torso yeah
you are moving the hip you have to move
the hip okay so we do it
eight times to each side eight times to
one side and then it turns to the other
let's do it together one
and two as big as you can three
four five
six seven
and eight and now eight in the direction
one two
three four
five six
seven and eight
okay good and the last one
is extremely important for balance yeah
we're going to target
the muscles of the ankle and the lower
leg yeah and that's basically what you
need for balance balance is a matter of
your core one thing yeah that your core
is tight
but most importantly of the muscles
right here yeah on the lower leg
and this exercise targets that in a
in a soft way because you are using both
legs yeah
so you have to make sure that your feet
are completely
together yeah the whole side of the foot
is touching the other side including the
tip yeah
because otherwise when you go up your
feet will be open
and that's not good yeah so keep your
feet together
and then grab your hips if you want you
go down you flex the knees
this is just to relax in between going
up
and then you stretch the knees you put
your weight
a little bit forward so that you can
lift your heels
and go on the toes or the ball
and the toes yeah keep your core tight
and then hold this stretch this position
a few seconds it helps if you look
forward in the horizon
yeah if you choose a point in front of
you and you keep looking at it
then go down slowly don't go down
like this yeah go down in a controlled
way
okay and then we bend again and bounce
bounce bounce three times and then
up okay so let's do it day times
together grab your hips
feet together and then bend your knees
bounce bounce bounce then stretch the
knees go
up and hold it a few seconds yeah
just a few seconds look in front of you
and then
go down controlled control slowly
two bubbles bounce bounce
go up hold it
and then down three bounce bounce bounce
and go down four bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it
and go down five bounce bounce bounce
and go down six thumbs bounce
bounce one hold it
and go down seven bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it
go down and the last one eight bounce
bounce bounce
go up hold it
and go down slowly
okay good so we
are warming up we are ready for the
first exercise
okay this is the first part of the
combination if you watch the previous
video
this will look very familiar because we
start in a pasadena position
like this yeah my weight is on the right
leg the knee is bent
i am low and the left leg is free and
straight in front of me
this is the position that the follower
would use to do another forward with a
pasada
and then i step forward towards my right
side and a back step
yeah pasada forward side that's
what the follower is doing so the
combination start like this
yeah embrace put the arms quite low
yeah not up low and the first thing you
do is you change
weight from the right foot to the left
forward and at the same time you do 180
degrees pivot to the right like this
and then you are up because your
standing leg is straight
from here you go down again you bend the
left knee and then you do a step forward
with right
and at the same time you turn the torso
to the right
because now you are anticipating 180
degrees pivot
to the right when you do the pivot if
you can
keep the free leg behind like this
one and then pass through zero and then
pass out position again
and that's the combination yeah again
passada position
change weight forward with 180 degrees
pivot
go up go down again
step forward with torsion to the right
180 degrees pivot free leg behind pass
through zero
passado okay that's the combination
so let's do it eight times
turning towards the right with the
metronome
so bpm
two bits per bar yeah and we will do it
very slowly
we will do assad and change weight
pivot step
okay let's do it eight times and we will
wait also two bits between repetitions
okay so let's go eight times
to step
two
three
foreign
six
seven
hey
okay good now we do it
eight times but turning to the left
yeah so now everything is reversed my
weight is on the
left leg the knee is bent my right leg
is in front of me
free and straight and then i change my
weight
forward with a pivot to the left 180
degrees i go up
now i go down again i step forward
with left turning the torso to the left
anticipating the pivot i keep my three
leg behind
and then i pass through zero and pass
out again okay
so let's do it eight times slowly to the
left
and one
two
three
four
five
six
eight
okay good eight times
try to do the step relax don't be tense
yeah you're here and then
relax here and in the pivot relax
yeah because this will help your balance
now let's do it
fast so we will set an extra
subdivision on the
on the metronome like this yeah
and we will do it in half the time
and because we will take half the time
we will do it 16 times to each time
so 16 times to the left 16 times to the
right
okay so i do it once so that you see
what the speed is before you we do it
together yeah
it would be like this look it will be
like
one bump up okay
one two three that's it
okay so let's do it sixteen times
to the right so my weight is on the
right leg
and the left leg is in position
one
two
three relax
four
five
six
seven
eight eight more one
two be precisely the time
three step by step
four
five
six
seven
okay
okay yeah now 16 times to the other side
and one thing is that when you're doing
the pivot
yeah the big pivot at the end don't rush
to move your free leg forward yeah
you are doing the keyboard don't rush to
put this
leg forward yeah i recommend you to
relax when you are doing the trilogy
relax and imagine that you're in no rush
to do that step why because your pivot
will be better
if you are calm and if you lift the leg
behind and then
you can always do this movement very
fast at the end
yeah so instead of rushing like this
yeah no do it like this relax
yeah you will be on time don't worry
okay
so now we do it to the
left yeah so my weight is on the left
leg
the right leg is free in front of me in
pasta position
so let's do it 16 times
one
two
three
four relaxed
five
six
seven
eight eight more
one be precise with the time
two one
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay great
so another thing especially when you do
it fast
if you see we are using only two
directions yeah
we start like this we turn to the other
side
and then we turn to this side so it's
always here
and here so in each change of direction
try to find with your eyes the new
direction as quickly as possible
yeah one spot yeah and then
one spot and this will help you
with your balance and to be precise yeah
okay let's go to the next to the next
exercise okay so now we will add a few
more steps to what we have
yeah so the beginning will be the same
you start
in pasadena position you transfer the
weight
pivot you up now you go down step
forward
torsion and pivot but now comes the
change because after the pivot
you change weight in zero position you
stay low
and you change weight and then you do a
second step forward
with the right leg yeah then with this
step
again torsion in the torso because now
you're anticipating a pivot that is a
bit bigger 270 degrees
because here you are going to end with a
size step
and in the pivot you will do
an adornment you will lift the foot like
this
and then sidestep and then you transfer
the weight to your left leg and to
finish
you do a 90 degrees pivot to the right
you change weight and then pasada
position again so you
finish where you started yeah let's do
it again
pasada position transfer the weight
forward
pivot 180 degrees up go down
step forward torsion pivot
180 degrees change weight step forward
torsion pivot 270 with adornment
side step 90 degrees change weight
and pasada okay position
so technical things you start low
yeah you start with the knee bend you
start on the
pivot you go up now your legs
are straight so you are up you go down
again
and then here yeah torsion
when you pivot yeah keep the leg behind
and then change weight here first is the
pivot and then the changing way
people change of weight and then another
step forward
here when you are going to do the
alignment
um the adornment with the free leg
happens
almost by itself if you accentuate
this torsion if you accentuate this
movement
the leg will go up almost by itself
you see then the abdomen will look very
relaxed
and then here side step 90 degrees pivot
stay low yeah every time that we change
weight
in zero position we always keep
our knees bent yeah change
and pass okay so i hope that was clear
let's do it eight times
slowly to the right
yeah and as always
58 bpm
and two each third bar yeah so get ready
put your weight on the right foot bend
the knee
left foot in front of you free leg
and embrace elizabeth eight times
slowly
[Music]
two
ready
four
five
six
we precisely beat yeah
eight two
two
okay good if you
have problems following what the
follower is doing
yeah figuring out what the follower is
doing is very easy she's just doing a
hero around him
so i'm going to tell you now what the
follower is doing
she's doing pasada step forward
then step side in front of me
then step back
then back side front back
side front and then
side and we stop there yeah that's what
she's doing
okay so now let's do the same but
to the left yeah to the other side
and let's be precise with the bits of
the metal knob
so you really have to control the speed
of your movements
okay and balance is very important so
get ready
weight on the left right foot in front
of you
let's do that time slowly
one
two
ready
for
bye
see
seven
hey
okay good
be careful on the pivot yeah
when you are doing the
tap now on this pivot be careful that
you finish the pivot
because if not you will have this
problem
your feet will look like this so to
avoid this
you really need to engage your middle
yeah
and finish the pivot open here
so that in the side step your feet look
paddle or if you come a little bit open
yeah and then you finish
okay so now we will do the same but
fast yeah i do it once
before we go for it so that you see the
speed
yeah so you start at least and the
exercise now goes this fast look
[Music]
so now let's do it for real let's go for
it yeah so
wait on the right left in pasadena
position
and we do everything to the right
get ready and go one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
we do it only eight times the last one
okay good don't let your arms open
on the pills yeah keep your arms
always come back and close so let's do
it
eight times now to the left
so weight on the left leg bend
and the right foot is in front of your
impact position
so let's go eight times
one
two
three
relax four
be precise with a beat yeah
six
seven
hey
okay great
good let's go to the next exercise
okay let's add a few more steps to what
we have already
yeah so the beginning is already clear
yeah you start in a saddle position
and then you change your weight forward
with a 180 degrees people to the right
and you go up
then you go down you do a forward step
with right
using torsion in the torso then 180
degrees pivot to the right
and then change of weight in zero
position another
uh step forward with right now 270
degrees pivot to the right
with adornment yeah using the knee and
side step using this line
yeah and here comes the new part
instead of changing weight in zero
position after the side step we do
back yeah for those who didn't watch the
previous video puntel comes from spanish
it means point
and you're basically doing a point on
the floor with your big toe
thumb and the accent is when the foot is
going
up and not when the foot goes down yeah
so we do up until and then a step
forward
with the right leg following the same
line yeah
until forward and then another
pivot of 180 degrees to the right
with change of weight yeah we repeat
this movement again step four with right
270 degrees period with adornmentary
side step and we finish here with a 90
degrees pivot
change weight in zero position and
passada position again
okay now
uh as you probably noticed i finish
the combination in the opposite
direction from where i started yeah
i started like this and now i finish
like this
but that's okay because we are not done
yet yeah
so every time we repeat this combination
we will start in the opposite direction
that's fine okay now let's go again
quickly through the whole
combination that we have now and let's
see a few technical details
so you start low remember yeah you bend
the knee
your right leg so you start low and when
you change the weight and you do the
first feel
you walk up yeah your legs are straight
and then you
bend the knee again before the step when
you do the step forward with the right
leg
remember to turn the torso uh before
yeah anticipate the pivot then you only
need to
use your hip change weight and then
front
here again uh here is even more
important because the pivot is bigger
is 270 degrees and the torsion of the
torso helps
to bend the knee and do the environment
and then here
side step until back
you should do this low yeah with a knee
bend
then step forward stay low because now
we do
again pivot and change of weight
step stay low 270 degrees pivot so
remember
torsion is very important before the
pivot again a dormant
side step and here stay low because
we still have a change of weight in zero
position
and then we finish in pascal position
okay
so there is only one moment where you go
up
which is this the very beginning
from here the rest is always down okay
good so we will do it now eight times
with the metronome slowly
uh going to the right yeah
then we will do it again to the left and
then quick
okay so we'll do it with the metronome
58 bpm
two bits per bar
and let's go let's do it slowly yeah so
focus
on being precise with the beat and on
doing
clean movements controlled three
movements yeah especially the pivots
okay so weight on the right bend the
knee
left leg stretch in front of you three
and let's go
one until
and wait
two
wait
time
for
[Music]
bye
okay
seven
um hey
okay very slowly so uh let's do it now
eight times
to the left to the other side so
weight is now on the left leg the right
leg is free
in front of you and we will take times
together
one
[Music]
until
two
three
four
bye
[Music]
six
seven
um hey
unfinished okay
good so
pay attention to the pivots now make
sure that you finish them completely
because otherwise if you don't
you might have this problem yeah the
pivot wasn't finished
and then on the sides that afterwards
your feet
look like this they look at each other
so uh
that looks horrible so you have to
anticipate with the torso
and then engage your hip so that
you open completely yeah
and your foot looks actually
[Music]
on the other direction yeah looks open
and then on the sides that
your feet are looking a bit away from
each other yeah
which is much better okay so pay
attention to that
and now we will set an extra supervision
on the metronome and uh
we will do it in half the time yeah
eight times to the left and eight times
to the right
okay so get ready
uh you can just watch me wait a few
times
and then you can rewind and start with
me again yeah if you want to see
how the speed is yeah i'm just going to
do it
okay so get ready knees together
you need less compact weight on the
right
left leg free extend in front of you and
the heel goes to the right
okay so eight times let's do it together
one
one way
two
all right
four
five
ah six
um
um hey
okay yeah if you watch programs
following the speed that is too fast you
can do small steps
that helps a lot yeah so here
instead of doing this yeah
no you don't need to do such big steps
you can just do this one
pump that's it
you see if you reduce the figure you
will be able to
do it at this speed easier yeah it won't
cause so much effort okay
so let's do it eight times but now to
the left
so the weight is on the left leg knee is
bent and the right leg is in front of
you
free and extended for the facade
okay so let's do it eight times together
[Music]
fast
one two
three
um
six
and seven
um hey
um yeah
that's it okay so um
uh you might get dizzy huh it's normal
because you are
spinning a lot and doing it fast so a
few tips to
avoid getting dizzy is
the first one think about the
combination
as a series of photos in argentina many
teachers use this term
photo to refer to a very clear position
for example this
and this yeah and photo usually means a
position between steps
so the combination is a series of photos
you have this photo and then you have
this photo and then this photo
and then this photo and then
this photo this photo
this photo and this one
yeah so you concentrate on hitting each
photo clearly
and the transitions between photos you
do them
fast yeah you learn quick so that you
are
ready to arrive to the next photo on
time
yeah and this helps a lot
yeah especially it helps that the photos
are
uh in between steps so you don't have
the problem that you have
to wait in one leg or that the photo is
when you have the weight on one leg
which will be difficult
and anyway you don't have time yeah and
the second tip
is try to really find
as soon as possible the next direction
yeah so for example
when you are here and you start try to
find the opposite direction
quickly yeah quickly so that you have a
target
yeah then when you do the step here
anticipate
yeah make the step a bit shorter if you
have problems a bit smaller
and anticipate with the torso yeah
because then
your mind is already thinking about the
next direction
and then it will be very easy to arrive
here
fast the same here anticipate
yeah when you dance the combination your
head is always a bit ahead
of the current step and this helps you
a lot to reach the target the next photo
okay
so but anyway like everything else it
takes practice
okay so let's go to the next exercise
okay so this is the last part we will
add a few more steps to what we have
and then we will have the complete
combination
okay so i will show you what we have
already
and then the new part yeah let's go
through the combination
so we start on the passata position
and then we have the change of weight
front with 180 degrees pivot
going up then you bend the standing leg
and then you go front with right yeah
and then
180 degrees pivot with change of weight
in zero position
and again front with right then we have
the 270 degrees pivot with
adornment and then sidestep then
comes the punter back
front step with right and then again 180
degrees people to the right
change your weight to zero position and
then again
front with right 270 degrees pivot
to the right with an ornament and side
step
yeah this is what we have until now now
the new part
looks like this after the side step we
will do
something similar to the pontero but
instead of the punter we will cross
the leg back the right leg we will do an
arc on the floor yeah don't lift the
foot
on the floor and then crossing back
and bending both knees then from here
the weight is on the right leg we do a
front step with left
and here we do a very similar movement
to the
first one that we have in the
combination we do
180 degrees pivot to the right and
we go up at the same time and we close
the legs
yeah this is very similar to what we do
in the beginning
then from here we go down again and we
go front with right
270 degrees pivot to the right
with adornment and then another side
step
and here we do an adornment with the
right leg
which looks like this yeah
it's not this idea it's not aboleo it's
more like
if you wanted to hit the lower part of
your bum
with your heel yeah so you flex
the foot you bend the knee and
you do this and then you put the foot
again
down where it was front okay
and here we finish the combination we do
a change of weight in zero position
and then two side steps one side step to
the right
close feet one side step to the left
this will be two inches back of the
woman yeah and then change weight
and then pass on again that's the whole
combination
and you finish in the same direction
that you started
yeah this direction okay let's go
through it again
pasada change your weight forward 180
degrees period
go up now flex forward left
180 degrees pivot change your weight in
zero position
front with right then 270 degrees
teamwork adornment side step
punter back front with right
180 degrees pivot change of weight in
zero position
forward with right 270 degrees pivot to
the right
adornment side step close back
bend both knees weight on the right
front step 180 degrees pivot to the
right
collect the legs go low
go down again front with right 170
degrees
270 degrees pivot to the right with
adornment
um now the second kind of adornment you
hit your bum with the heel and then
front change weight in zero position
side step to the right side step to the
left
change weight bend the knee and then
pass our position again
okay i hope you could follow the whole
thing
now uh
what is the follower doing during the
whole
combination well um how do you keep
track of her steps
it's not that difficult look the first
thing you need to do
in order to make it easier for yourself
to
track her steps is to reduce her steps
to just
three elements yeah three elements one
element
is when the follower is doing her front
step okay
the second element is when she's doing
the side step
and the third element is when she's
doing her
back side and front step yeah
back side front these three steps yeah
back side front we treat them as a unit
as one movement yeah so we have three
front side or
back side front okay now every time the
leader
is doing a side step in the combination
every time we have a side step the woman
is always
going front she's always going to the
front step
yeah and the direction of her front step
is opposite of my side step so if i use
my left leg to go to the left
with my side step the woman is going
towards my right
okay now every time you go front
yeah you go front she's either doing her
side step
or she's doing her back side
front element yeah
so when she does the side step yeah
usually that's when we always have
the 180 degrees fever change weight in
zero position and then front again with
the same leg
yeah but when she's doing her
back side front element that's when we
have
the 270 degrees pivot with an element
and then the sides
yeah so it's all very logical
yeah so now i will go again through the
whole combination but this time
i will say what the follower is doing
yeah so you will see how this method
how the system works uh in real life
yeah so we start on the pasada position
and at this point the woman is in front
of me and she's doing another
forward with her right leg and she's
going to do a pasada
over my foot yeah now she
will go on her front step she will do
her front step towards my right side
and then that's when the whole hero
starts so the woman is doing
pasada front step
side yeah and
back side front
okay now side step
and back side
front and
side step this is a sakada on her side
step
back side front
and then side step in front of me
yeah and here we break
the heel because after her side step
i change my weight in zero position and
then she does a back step
but this is a bad culture because i
follow her with a side step
and then i need a pivot i need another
back coach
yeah i go with her with a side step and
then i need
another pivot but instead of being an
ocho what i do is i need the pivot i
change weight i
cut her back and it becomes a little
bolero because she comes back
um to return to my foot
when i go into the pasadena position
yeah so at the end now i'm
the follower yeah i do the steps of the
followers so at the end
i do the side step the leader comes
front
inside my side step then he changes
weight in zero position
and he does a side step with me so i
don't know back
and then he leads another option so i do
another direction back and that's her
his second side step and then he leads
another pivot
but then he cuts it with a change of
weight in zero position
and then he brings me back
to his passada okay yes
i hope that was clear yeah
you can go again through this
explanation and
um until you you see it until you get it
yeah
so now we will practice the whole
combination
first slowly eight times to the right
then to the left and then eight times
quickly fast to the right and to the
left yeah so with the metronome
so as always 58 bpm
it for bar and we will do it
slowly now yeah we'll practice slowly so
focus on balance on finding your axes
on moving your feet on the floor clean
on remembering when are you supposed to
go up or
low yeah okay so let's go
one
cross
[Music]
okay
foreign
bye
so
six
seven
hey
okay eight times now we will do the same
but to the other side yeah to the left
so the weight is on the left leg knee is
belt
and the right leg is in front of you
free and
straight okay so let's go
eight times together
on one
my government
so
three
four
five
two
think
seven
so
um hey
okay good now
we will do it eight times
fast that is in a realistic speed the
speed that you would use
when dancing this for real eight times
to each side yeah so we put a
subdivision here
to help us be precise with the
half times that we need yeah
yeah okay so
we do it down to the right so weight on
the right foot
on the right leg knee is bent left leg
is in front of you
in pasadena position yeah
one
two
three
four
bye
six
seven
hey
okay good now we're going
eight times to the left so i will
do it now in this position this
direction
waiting on the left right leg in front
of you free
without weight for the facade of the
woman
okay let's do it eight times
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
hey
okay good so that was it
i hope you like this combination it
would be very useful
when you are doing heroes and you want
to try different ideas
different changes of weight which length
as what
different adornments during the hero and
one thing i wanted to tell you about
speed about doing things fast don't
obsess with speed when you practice
speed is something that dancers use
to make things more exciting yeah more
more spectacular
and more surprising because they happen
fast
but when you are practicing
when you do things very fast it will
always take your technique down yeah
so i recommend that you focus on
practicing slowly yeah with a slow tempo
and that will give you the opportunity
to work
deeply into the aspects that actually
make your dance look good
and clean for example your buttons yeah
that when you're practicing something
you always find your axis you always
feel you have a good balance and that
you are not
wobbling or falling around the direction
of your steps
that you are precise with your
directions that you are using the right
line
for your steps and not some weird
diagonal
the for example the pivots that you
finish the pivots yeah that you engage
your needle
your hip and you finish the pivot so
that in the next step your feet don't
look wrong
yeah that they look right and timing
also that when you change your weight
when you put the foot on the floor
it's not too early it's not too late
it's right on the beat
and that needs control that makes good
balance
and that needs a lot of control and
that's why dancing fast
is easier than dancing slow
or better said when you dance fast
and you have problems and you have
mistakes and your technique is not right
it's much easier to hide those mistakes
because you're moving fast that means
that the next movement is coming right
away
so if you had bad balance or your feet
were not so good
then you can hide it because you are on
the next step
right away there is no time to see the
mistake
and that's why dancing slowly is much
more challenging
because you have to spend more time
on one foot doing one movement so if you
have a problem
with balance with your feet with your
direction
and you're dancing slowly it will be
much clearer
it will be much easier to see the
mistake so that's why dancing slowly
is more difficult than dancing fast
and also it gives you the opportunity to
work
really well on these basic aspects
okay so really i mean
i show you here um the combination
slowly
and then fast in half time and that's a
big jump
on speed but i do it in this way because
i want to show you the two extremes but
i recommend
and this is what i would do if i wasn't
recording the class but
just working for myself that
first you do it slowly and you repeat it
until the basic aspects of your
technique are clean
and for that recording yourself is a
very good feedback i recommend it as
well
and then try to work on speed because
you have to
but work gradually in small increments
and that's why working with a metronome
is very useful because you can change
the tempo
in very small amounts yeah so
increase your tempo do it again make
sure that your technique
stays clean and then increase the tempo
and more
and if you hit a speed where you start
having problems
where your pivots are not good or your
balance is not good then go
lower again yeah decrease the tempo
and then make sure that those basic
aspects are clean
and then progress to a faster speed but
do it
slowly okay so that's it i hope you
like the class practice a lot thank you
for
the people who are supporting the
channel with donations
and i look forward to see you in the
next video bye bye